اود ان اشير الى اشكال حصل هنا في المركز
الذي اتواجد فيه مركز بيشكتاش هذه المنطقه
محسوبه على المعارضه التركيه تعرض فريق
العربيه
للمضايقات من احدى السيدات التابعات والتي
تعمل في الداخل مع كمال كليتش دار اوغلو
او حزب الشعب منذ اللحظه التي سمعتني فيها
اتحدث باللغه العربيه قالت لي يجب ان
تذهبوا وتخرجوا من هذا المكان يعني
المشاكل هي من وراء العرب هذه تحديدا
الكلمات التي تفوهت بها
وتدخل شخص اخر وطلبها بالكف عن ذلك لانه
نحن حاصلون على يعني تصريح من وزاره
الاعلام وايضا اخذنا اذن من الشرطه
المتواجده هنا توسع الاشكال الى حد كبير
وتدخلت الشرطه بين يعني حتى هناك شخص اخر
هو من المراقبين من الداخل لم
نعلم مركزه ما هو الان هدات الاوضاع